[Music]
famously and everyone was talking about
it about a year ago or so you declared
bankruptcy you said you're out of money
and then you irritated the judge in the
case because you started posting all
these pictures of you that seemed to
indicate that you have a ton of money
you put up this picture right here of
you eating a money sandwich well I for
one can tell you how you went broke
[Applause]
you put this picture up of you opening
your fridge and just finding money
inside you put up this picture these are
yours of your coffee table which is made
of money then you put this picture up
right here which says you're broke
though their money and then this one
right here which is just cash coming out
of your pants so why were you doing that
maldis doesn't understand the difference
between chapter 11 the chapter 7 yeah
well you finally chapter 11 you just
really reorganize you reorganize it's
nice I got four companies that over like
three or four million dollars in each
one of us right
I can pull the money out and take those
pictures right but the course is going
you know their responsibility to make
sure that is a paid because they got to
receive these awards from different
arbitrators and different things and
it's interesting because once you're
successful and you publicly know that
you become a target bullseye
yeah the lawyers do everything in
contingent on getting something from you
right they sue you for know that but
that still begs the question if that's
the situation well I put all that that's
over with now going
it really makes me want to visit your
home though and just hang out there for
an hour you know walk out of there with
30,000 can I get a Kleenex yeah you're
out of toilet paper
[Laughter]
you